son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna ustedes Les agradecemos
su sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
Colombia y Guatemala llamaron a
consultas a sus embajadoras a causa del
proceso que la fiscalía guatemalteca
prevé de abrir contra Iván Velázquez
actual ministro de defensa colombiano y
quien fue presidente de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en
Guatemala lo acusan de corrupción
vinculada con odebrecht
el gobierno peruano aseguró que se
prepara para la llegada de miles de
manifestantes que marchan hacia lima y
que prevén una toma de la ciudad del
miércoles y jueves los ciudadanos llevan
semanas protestando para pedir la
renuncia de la presidenta Dina boluarte
la disolución del Congreso y el adelanto
de elecciones hablamos con algunos de
ellos
en Ucrania los combates se centran en
las afueras y el centro de bad mut una
de las ciudades más disputadas en los
Casi 11 meses de guerra Rusia dijo que
se hizo con el control pero Ucrania
desmintió la información y aseguró que
la batalla continúa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio con la atención que
enfrenta a Colombia y a Guatemala el
presidente guatemalteco Alejandro
yamatei cargó contra su homólogo
colombiano Gustavo Petro y aseguró que
está cometiendo El error de un
guerrillero al tiempo que lo calificó de
poco político ambos gobiernos llamaron a
consultas a sus embajadoras luego de que
la fiscalía guatemalteca denunciaron
proceso contra Iván Velázquez actual
ministro de defensa colombiana y
expresidente de la Comisión
Interamericana contra la impunidad en
Guatemala sisic según las autoridades
guatemaltecas Velázquez abusó de su
poder a la aprobar acuerdos de
cooperación supuestamente anómalos con
dos directivos brasileños de odebrecht
en 2017 Ramiro cuevalverena tiene los
detalles
el choque diplomático es un hecho
embajadoras convocadas versiones
cruzadas entre presidentes y
funcionarios que temen una posible
ruptura de las relaciones bilaterales la
atención va en aumento entre Colombia y
Guatemala la razón las acciones legales
que la fiscalía especial guatemalteca
anunció que inicia contra Iván Velázquez
actual ministro de defensa colombiano y
antiguo director de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en
Guatemala respaldada por Naciones Unidas
que la fiscalía especial contra la
impunidad emprenderá las acciones
legales correspondientes para que
respondan por sus actos ilegales
arbitrarios y abusivos el ex comisionado
de la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala sic y Iván
Velázquez Gómez y la ex funcionaria de
sisic Luz Adriana Camargo garzón
el fiscal Rafael currucciche apunta que
Velázquez debe responder por actos
ilegales arbitrarios y abusivos por la
recepción de sobornos en un expediente
corrupción que lo enlaza con la
constructora brasileña odebrecht sin
embargo curruc Chiche está en la lista
Engel de Estados Unidos acusado de
obstruir investigaciones y desbaratar
casos de corrupción contra altos
funcionarios el caso contra Velázquez
provocó el rechazo de países extranjeros
como Estados Unidos y el repudio del
presidente Gustavo Petro quien catalogó
el proceso como una persecución y quiero
defenderemos
él seguirá siendo nuestro ministro
si Guatemala insiste
en apresar hombres justos bueno
Velázquez lideró la investigación en
Guatemala que terminó con la división
del presidente Otto Pérez Molina en 2017
quien recibió una condena de 16 años por
corrupto el colombiano fue cesado de la
comisión internacional por decisión Del
mandatario Jimmy Morales que cerró la
entidad en 2019
en sus 11 años de funcionamiento la
comisión impulsó casos que implicaron a
680 personas entre funcionarios y
empresarios ganó 310 condenas y
desmanteló 60 redes criminales en un
país que ha obligado el exilio a cinco
agentes de la ley en tres años Por
investigar a miembros del gobierno vamos
a Perú donde el gobierno de Dina
boluarte pidió que la llamada toma de
Lima que planea el manifestantes de
otras regiones del país para el
miércoles y jueves se lleve a cabo en
paz la mandataria aseguró que espera
poder dialogar con los ciudadanos que se
han movilizado y bloqueado vías durante
las últimas semanas pero agregó que la
policía se prepara para levantar los
bloqueos los manifestantes piden la
renuncia del ejecutivo la disolución del
Congreso y el adelanto de elecciones
estamos aquí pidiendo justicia que haga
justicia pesos muertos que no sea en
vano esos muertos tantos niños que están
quedando fue huérfano señora Dina yo
quiero que me escuches o Asesinan
queremos que se vaya que renuncie el
pueblo no le ha elegido queremos que nos
escuchen a nivel de todo el Perú Lima
que nos escucha a nivel internacional
Cómo es que mataron a nuestros hermanos
a nuestros hijos que es solamente han
hecho el uso de sus derechos Cuál es
reclamar a través de esta protesta
pacífica ya se encuentran en Venezuela
los delegados del gobierno colombiano
para reunirse de manera extraordinaria a
partir de mañana con los representantes
de la guerrilla del eln el encuentro
tiene lugar en un momento de tensión
entre las partes dado que el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro afirmó que
este grupo guerrillero había pactado
bilateral del fuego Por espacio de seis
meses una afirmación desmentida por el
eln sobre este reinicio de las
conversaciones se refirió el embajador
de Colombia en Venezuela Armando
Benedetti
saludamos y le damos la bienvenida a la
delegación de paz del gobierno para los
diálogos con el eln hoy en Caracas
confiamos en que el jefe de la
delegación OTI Patiño el comisionado de
paz Danilo Rueda José Félix lafoury y
todo el equipo logren Ahora sí una paz
real y duradera vamos ahora con
información de la guerra en Ucrania
porque en terrenos se intensificaron los
bombardeos rusos en las afueras de
guajute también en el centro de la
ciudad el 13 de enero del grupo
paramilitar ruso Wagner se hizo con el
control de soledad con la intención de
ampliar su control sobre la zona Alba
Santana nos hace un recuento de lo que
ha ocurrido en esta zona de nietzk
todo empezó el 7 de mayo de 2022 en
mitad de la madrugada los ataques rusos
llegaron a Back mood y no han cesado
desde entonces varios edificios quedaron
reducidos a cenizas y muchos civiles
resultaron heridos A mediados de junio
mientras su cráneo intentaba plantar
cara los ataques rusos los bombardeos
siguieron y forzaron a mucha gente
abandonar la ciudad donde debería ir
dónde debería dormir
y no está claro cuando Habrá más
bombardeos si habrá más explosiones en
la noche pero la situación no había
escalado del todo hasta Julio
cuando Rusia bombardeó tres de
asentamientos en la zona con un número
desconocido de civiles muertos y heridos
Y es que badmud es un punto estratégico
en esta guerra perteneciente adoníes que
en el don Bass tomar la ciudad
afianzaría el control ruso en la región
que ya declara como suya desde
septiembre pero lo cierto Es que Bad
mood se le ha resistido a Rusia y
también a Ucrania convirtiéndolo en uno
de los puntos más sangrientos de la
guerra pero dónde me voy a ir mi hija
murió en la cantera un proyectil alcanzó
mi casa
no iré a ningún sitio no la he enterrado
aún sigue ahí bajo los escombros no
puedo lo siento
en septiembre los rusos atacaron 11
localidades cerca del frente y más gente
decidió irse de la ciudad de los 70.000
que eran antes de la guerra Sólo quedan
cerca de Diez mil
con combates incesantes en diciembre la
ofensiva rusa se intensificó y los
civiles que aún están allí tuvieron que
celebrar la Navidad entre bombardeos
ahora la situación no es mejor con
ataques diarios el 13 de enero Rusia se
hizo con el control de soledad en las
afueras de bakmuth su primera Gran
Victoria en la zona en un año que ahora
amenaza con llegar hasta bakmut y la
segunda jornada del foro económico
mundial giró en torno al apoyo
internacional para Ucrania la Unión
Europea desembolsó los primeros tres mil
millones de euros de un paquete de
18.000 para 2023 que busca garantizar el
funcionamiento de servicios públicos y
afrontar las principales necesidades
Daniel hablando con enviada especial de
France 24 a Suiza nos amplió los
detalles
Ucrania no estaba llamada a ser la gran
protagonista de este foro económico
mundial en davos sin embargo lo que
terminó ocurriendo fue lo contrario y es
que ha sido el plato fuerte del día hoy
en los discursos de los diferentes
líderes mundiales que han participado
por ejemplo la propia olana se lesca la
esposa del presidente
estuvo aquí enviándole un mensaje al
mundo para pedir más cooperación
cooperación en que la Unión Europea ya
le ha prometido tres mil millones de
euros que fueron desembolsados en las
últimas horas y también un paquete
adicional para llegar a 18.000 millones
de euros en lo largo de todo este año
también hay presión sobre Alemania para
que permita el envío de tanques de
fabricación alemana en los leopard que
son bastante utilizados por los
ejércitos en Europa
el canciller olafones estará mañana
presente en ese foro económico mundial y
previo a esta participación ya los
presidentes de Polonia y de lituania le
pidieron que reconsiderara su a la
exportación de estos tanques Alemania ha
sido bastante cautelosa porque cree que
esto podría desencadenar en un conflicto
aún peor y que inclusive podría llegar a
generarse un conflicto entre Rusia y la
otan justamente hoy el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden recibió en la
casa blanca al Primer Ministro de Países
Bajos Mark quien anunció que su gobierno
planea enviar sistemas antimisiles a
Ucrania sumándose a Washington y a
Berlín de acuerdo con el líder
neerlandés no se puede permitir que el
presidente Vladimir Putin no rinda
cuentas por su invasión a Ucrania añadió
que es fundamental llevarlo ante los
tribunales la Casa Blanca informó además
que los líderes acordaron profundizar su
cooperación en temas transatlánticos y
globales mutuos
en otras noticias el presidente de
Vietnam
presentó su carta de renuncia a los
legisladores su Partido Comunista lo
responsabiliza de los delitos cometidos
por funcionarios en los últimos meses
junto su partido como la policía han
investigado actos de corrupción en el
país y en 2022 esto subieron un 50%
respecto a 2021 más de 500 miembros del
partido de puc fueron procesados
incluidos tres ministros y dos
viceprimeros ministros
por primera vez desde los años 60 hubo
un descenso poblacional en China el
gobierno afirmó que las muertes
superaron a los nacimientos y la tasa de
natalidad continúa bajando
progresivamente lo que preocupa a la
nación más poblada del mundo por el
envejecimiento de su población y el
impacto que esto pueda tener en la
capacidad de China para mantener su
papel de superpotencia mundial veamos
más detalles en el informe
descenso de la población por primera vez
en más de 60 años el año pasado hubo en
China casi un millón de nacimientos
menos que el año anterior
de hecho la tasa de natalidad de china
en 2022 fue menos de la mitad que hace
10 años con sólo 6,77 nacimientos por
cada mil habitantes
una cifra 10 puntos menos que la tasa de
natalidad de India y cinco puntos por
debajo de Francia pero aún más
significativo la cantidad de muertes en
el país superó a la de nacimientos el
primer caso de este tipo desde 1961
durante el gobierno de maonk gran parte
del descenso demográfico es consecuencia
de la política del hijo único impuesta
entre 1980 y 2015 pero existen otras
razones para el descenso china es uno de
los países más caros del mundo para
criar a un niño
no tengo pensado tener hijos y aunque
algún día me casé me gustaría tener una
relación sin hijos
una combinación de factores que ha dado
lugar a una población cada vez más
envejecida y ha dado paso a la
preocupación de que un día china no
tenga suficientes personas en edad de
trabajar para seguir siendo una
superpotencia mundial el fenómeno se
vería reflejado en una escasez de mano
de obra que también reduciría los
ingresos Fiscales y las cotizaciones a
un sistema de pensiones Ya bajo presión
es preocupante porque los jóvenes ya no
quieren tener hijos porque el país
envejece Y eso crea presión en nuestra
sociedad
los gobiernos locales han puesto en
marcha varias medidas para animar a la
gente a tener más hijos entre ellas
deducciones Fiscales permisos de
maternidad más largos y ayudas a la
vivienda pero nos espera que estas
medidas sean suficientes para frenar la
tendencia a largo plazo en 2035 un
tercio de la población tendrá más de 60
años
y la persona con más edad en el mundo
falleció a los 118 años en Francia se
trata de
ordenada monja en una comunidad católica
en
1944 cuando tomó el nombre de hermana
Andre nació en 1904 y había sobrevivido
al covid en 2022
en otras noticias la cantante
estadounidense Madonna anunció una nueva
gira por América del Norte y Europa a
partir del 15 de julio la artista Busca
con este tour celebrar los éxitos más
representativos de su carrera como
cantante que le ha permitido tener 38
canciones en la lista Hot 100 de
billboard Madonna de celebration tour
como es llamada la gira recorrerá 35
ciudades en Canadá Estados Unidos en
donde visitará ciudades como Chicago
Nueva York Miami Denver Atlanta entre
otras Este primer tramo finalizará el 7
de octubre en Las Vegas Nevada
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros que
ella llega Andrés espinal con toda la
información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]